qué genial empezamos por fin una nueva
sección así que empezaremos la sección 9
de la página a 423 y bueno ya que
empezamos con mucho ánimo vamos a
resolver el problema número uno el
primer problema de esta sección que por
cierto dice si 5 tm es igual a 45 déjame
ponerlo aquí 5 veces este esto es igual
a 45 y además te por acá es igual a 1 y
además sabemos que está por acá esto es
igual a 1 lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale acá entonces yo lo que quiero saber
es el valor de acá cuánto vale camps muy
bien y si te das cuenta de esta ecuación
de una manera muy sencilla podemos
despejar atem si yo divido entre 5 esta
parte y entre 5 esta parte voy a llegar
a que estos dos se van ítem es igual a
40 y 55 lo cuáles no
entonces si te vale 9 a pues lo podemos
sustituir aquí yo sé que te por acá es
igual a 1 pero te vale 9 entonces 9 por
camps es igual a 1 y ahora está dividido
todo entre 9 esta parte dentro de 9 esta
parte entre 9 estos dos se van y me
queda que camps que es justo lo que yo
quería saber es igual a un noveno que
por cierto este es el inciso b así que
bueno empezamos con un problema bastante
sencillo que es el inciso b perfecto así
que vámonos al problema número dos que
me va a caber por aquí de una vez dice
si sabemos que 4 miro a una manivela no
no no no espera que estoy diciendo
parece que tengo dislexia es que todavía
estoy un poco dormido porque es bastante
temprano en este momento que estoy
haciendo el vídeo mi cerebro todavía no
funciona correctamente y bueno bueno
mejor leamos otra vez si sabemos que
cuatro giros a una
a una manivela abre dos centímetros una
ventana o claro claro claro si sabemos
que cuatro giros a una manivela vamos a
apuntar los cuatro giros abren una
ventana dos centímetros abren una
ventana dos centímetros si sabemos que
cuatro giros a una manivela abre dos
centímetros una ventana cuántos giros a
esa misma manivela se van a necesitar
para abrir la ventana tres centímetros y
medio entonces yo lo que quiero es abrir
esta ventana tres centímetros y medio
tres un medio de centímetros y bueno hay
varias formas de resolver esto
podríamos sacar cuántos centímetros se
abren por giro o lo que sea pero se me
ocurre que es mucho más fácil hacerlo
con una regla de tres yo lo que quiero
saber es cuántos giros vamos a necesitar
para abrir esta cantidad
centímetros y bueno que me dice una
regla de tres que hay que multiplicar
estos dos este por este y dividir entre
este entonces vamos a multiplicar estos
dos primero y dividir entre este y me
queda cuatro giros por tres enteros un
medio esto a todo esto hay que dividirlo
entre dos y bueno cuatro entre dos es
muy fácil esto me queda dos entonces
esto es lo mismo que dos que multiplican
a tres enteros un medio y bueno tres
enteros un médium es lo mismo que siete
medios dos por 3 617 entonces esto es lo
mismo que 2 por 7 medios y si yo canceló
este 2 con este 2
me quedan 7 es decir que necesitamos 7
giros para abrir la ventana tres y medio
centímetros y esto tiene mucha lógica
porque cuatro giros abre la ventana dos
centímetros si dividimos entre dos me va
a quedar que dos giros abren la ventana
un centímetro y si dividimos otra
entre dos me va a quedar que un giro
abre la ventana medio centímetro
solamente medio centímetro y si te das
cuenta tres un medio centímetros son
siete veces esto y por lo tanto
necesitamos siete giros que por cierto
otra vez es el inciso b así que vamos a
abordar este pizarrón y vamos a resolver
aquí el siguiente problema el problema
número tres el cual dice que si x entre
y esto es igual a dos tercios entonces
lo que me preguntan es a cuánto equivale
3x entre 2 james esto es lo que yo
quiero saber cuánto vale y bueno yo
tengo esta ecuación así que voy a partir
de aquí si yo lo que quiero hacer es
llegar de esta ecuación a esta expresión
que tengo aquí tengo que multiplicar la
parte de arriba por 3 entonces voy a
multiplicar la parte de arriba por 3 de
ambos lados de la ecuación
de este lado como de este lado pero
además tengo que dividir entre dos por
lo tanto tengo que dividir entre dos
este lado y también voy a dividir entre
dos este lado de tal manera que me va a
quedar 3x entre 2 y esto es igual a 3 x
2 lo cual es 6 entre 3 por 2 lo cual es
6 y entonces 3 x entre 2 jeff es 1 así
de fácil y así de sencillo estaba ese
problema que por cierto es el inciso c
la respuesta de este problema es el
inciso sem y el problema 4 no me cabe
aquí porque tiene tiene una figura
bastante bastante padre entonces déjenme
borrar esto y déjame intentar escribirte
por aquí el problema número 4 entonces
vamos a hacer la figura que me dice este
problema tengo una línea parecida
está
muy bien y después tengo una línea
perpendicular a esta así que vamos a
suponer que estas dos son rectas
perpendiculares muy bien y después tengo
una recta que para pasar por aquí va a
pasar por este punto y cruce y cruce
cruza por acá muy bien y después tengo
varios puntos entonces déjame escribirte
todos los puntos de este problema este
va a ser mi punto n después por aquí
tengo el punto r después por acá tengo
el punto s después tengo por aquí el
punto p a éste a este le voy a llamar
y por último tengo por aquí el punto
muy bien
ahora estas dos rectas son
perpendiculares es decir forman un
ángulo de 90 grados y me dicen que este
ángulo se llama x x grados este ángulo
de aquí me lo dan es 20 grados y este
ángulo de acá todo este es 10 grados muy
bien me dan esta figura en el problema
número 4 y ahora vamos a ver qué dice en
la siguiente figura ps y tr se
intersectan en el punto o ps iteere se
intersectan en el punto o que es justo
lo que tenemos aquí y por otra parte la
recta o n es perpendicular a la recta p
s estas dos rectas son perpendiculares y
bueno de hecho este es mi símbolo de
perpendicular este es mi símbolo de
perpendicular muy bien y entonces me
preguntan cuál es el valor de g
x cuál es el valor de g
- x y para responder a esta pregunta yo
te tengo una pregunta a ti qué ángulo de
todos estos es el ángulo opuesto ayer a
ver recordemos un poco si nosotros
tenemos dos rectas supongamos esta y
esta de aquí entonces los ángulos
opuestos que sería este y éste tienen el
mismo valor así que vamos a aplicar lo
mismo a esta figura que tengo aquí si te
das cuenta en esta figura que tengo aquí
estas dos rectas se intersectan en el
punto y déjeme remarcar las esta recta y
esta recta se interceptan en el punto o
y como se intersectan en el punto o date
cuenta que este ángulo es opuesto a qué
otro ángulo a este ángulo que tenemos
aquí
estos dos ángulos son ángulos opuestos y
si son ángulos opuestos entonces deben
de medir lo mismo fíjate qué curioso en
este problema nos dan un dato de más
nunca vamos a ocupar este ángulo de 20
porque que tengo que si estos dos
ángulos son opuestos entonces son
iguales y si son iguales entonces james
tiene que ser igual a este ángulo que
tengo aquí pero este ángulo que tengo
aquí es este ángulo recto que son 90
grados más
estos x grados por lo tanto todo este
ángulo es 90 grados más x grados y bueno
porque pongo esto aquí porque yo lo que
quiero saber es que menos x por lo tanto
de esta ecuación voy a restar x de ambos
lados entonces quito x aquí voy a quitar
a x también de este lado y que me va a
quedar bueno del lado izquierdo me queda
que menos x
esto tiene que ser igual estos dos se
van y me queda 90 menos x que es lo que
me pregunta el problema son 90 grados de
hecho es un ángulo recto y por cierto ya
está resuelto este problema es el inciso
c entonces ya tengo aquí otro problema
y vamos a ver el siguiente problema que
es el problema número 5 sin embargo
estoy viendo mi tiempo y estoy viendo
este problema que tiene una tabla
gigante por acá entonces creo que voy a
empezar el próximo vídeo con la tabla
del problema número 5 y así voy a cuidar
tu tiempo me voy a poner a trabajar en
la tabla del problema número 5 y lo
resolvemos en el siguiente vídeo así que
nos vemos en el siguiente